just I knew that you had two ex-wives
named Tammy so I was hoping that there
is one that you got along with no I hate
them both on my deathbed my final wish
is to have my ex-wives rushed to my side
so I can use my dying breath to tell
them both to go to hell one last time
would I get married again oh absolutely
if you don't believe in love what's the
point of living it's really good to see
you run you've aged horribly son of a
[ __ ] and didn't oh my god what is your
problem I did okay we're fine we're fine
please when you're metal in someone's
personal life it's just so rewarding
[Laughter]
is land good morning Jerry
that is a beautiful sweater vest April
you look like you could use $20 am i
right
why cuz you're a kid kids always need
money I need money ah that's why you're
my favorite Tom when Tiger Woods feels
invincible he wears a red shirt and
black pants good morning Ron where's the
same thing after he's had sex I'm a
simple man I like pretty dark-haired
women and breakfast food but this stock
photo I bought at a framing store isn't
real today I got the real thing a naked
Tammy made me breakfast this morning I
should have taken a picture of it
Diane is awesome and she likes you and
you like her I can tell Hey I don't
recall inviting you in here and B I did
not like her she's not my type
her life is messy Ron messy is fun okay
my whole life is a giant mess and I love
it look at me I have gum in my hair
listen I will not pursue Diane end of
story
excellent work everyone particularly you
Ron you have one very satisfied citizen
what did you do for her fixed her
pothole is that a euphemism no then
great work in fact she's out in the
hallway and wants to thank you herself
if you're here to complain about the
pothole I guarantee I did it correctly
actually I'm here to ask you out for
dinner really well I hope you're not the
kind of man who needs to ask the lady
out I'm a middle school vice-principal I
don't screw around does that freak you
out no on the contrary
so dinner please and thank you well
it'll be casual no need to wear makeup I
begrudging Lee admit that the 3-1-1
program is a moderate success I'm still
not sure why the citizen decided to come
speak with me in person but I'm just
happy to see a government program
finally work
call off the dogs you and I both know
that in my entire adult life I have
never checked a book out of the library
she's amazing oh I admit there was a
time when that sort of behavior would
have driven me wild but I'm in a healthy
relationship now tame a relationship
with him a lovely intelligent
self-possessed pediatric surgeon named
Wendy sounds like a real horror drippers
do nothing for me I like a strong
salt-of-the-earth self-possessed woman
at the top of her field
you're Steffi Graf's you're Sheryl
Swoopes Eze but I will take a free
breakfast buffet anytime anyplace
she just knows you so well I was
starting to wonder if I was ever gonna
get to that point I'm worried that maybe
there isn't room in your life for
another woman at this very moment Leslie
is throwing herself in front of a
freight train named Tammy for me and you
Leslie is a wonderful loyal friend who
was very important in my life but I
would sooner visit Europe then I have
something romantic happen between us
although if you'd like to visit Europe I
like you so much I'd be willing to risk
it but not France right god no see you
know me pretty well already but you're
about to get to know me even better I
brought you here because I want to show
you something that almost no one knows
about certainly not Tammy and not even
Leslie Knope ladies and gentlemen and
especially the ladies put your hands
together for the one the only my man mr.
Duke sue
a mighty fine holiday evening to you all
it might be cold outside but it's about
to get warm all up in my jazz I of
course I'm Duke silver and I would like
to dedicate this first song to my
Duchess what a surprise hey can we talk
maybe in private oh you and me
I believe she's referring to me son
please excuse us so I am pregnant I see
I don't understand how we were so
careful I warned you about this standard
birth control methods aren't usually
effective against a Swanson I got about
a million thoughts running around my
head but I really just want to know what
you're thinking okay here's what I'm
thinking I was gonna wait until our
anniversary take you somewhere romantic
perhaps in a canoe most likely in a
canoe I actually built a canoe for that
purpose but given the news and given my
significant feelings for you now seems
as good a time as any Ron Swanson Diane
Lewis will you marry me yes on one
condition anything my love ask me for
anything in the world and I'll give it
to you except a destination wedding just
the opposite
we'd both be married before I don't want
anything big or elaborate in fact the
smaller the better I assume you can deal
with that are you kidding as far as I'm
concerned we could go up to the fourth
floor right now Wow hello there hey
Leslie what's with the getup we're
coming back from our cleaning up a
Pawnee River is nothing I love more than
squeegeeing slime off a highway
underpass where are you
the fourth-floor getting married
okey-dokey well catch you later
are you dead you look like you're in
erectus I just I'm having so many
thoughts and feelings and I'm paralyzed
right now would you ladies like to come
can I be the best man why not let's go
Ron is getting married and I love him
and I care about him and this is the
greatest day ever and I do not have time
to talk about this if you would just
slow down a little then I could arrange
balloons or a flower cake or a bouncy
castles ah Ethel beavers we would like a
marriage license please and thank you
what's the date of the wedding today
it's a bit unusual but we don't care
Leslie Knope would you please be my
matron of honor Diane you have no idea
what that means to me she gets it let's
go oh this is like a waking nightmare
happiness um I need to get some flowers
uh why don't you hold this colorful
bouquet of highlighters right hi I need
to find some rice I need to throw some
rice
why is there no rice in this municipal
government building I found a justice
guy these are the marrying people this
is Carl hello Carl my fiance and I would
like to get married right now right here
haven't I done a quickie wedding for you
before it's certainly possible but this
one's going to stick I need your full
names for the license Ronald Ulysses
Swanson Diane Tammy Lewis Tammy your
middle name kidding it's Elizabeth let's
go Carl okay let's pump the brakes Carl
okay
belay that order Carl shortest possible
ceremony I'm tired of not being married
to this woman do you Ron Swanson okay
that's how were vested in me before you
Carl just one second I would just like
to give a short speech if I may you have
ten seconds at first glance it may seem
as though Ron Swanson and I have nothing
in common but Webster's dictionary
defines friend time Thank You Leslie I
could tell where you were going with it
and it was gonna be beautiful I now
pronounce you man and wife
great job everyone the reception will be
held in each of our individual houses
along
you